who are who are going to tell us about
some cool stuff um before we get started
I want to make a quick announcement uh
about the open problem session tomorrow
um so if you look on the schedule it
says like the last thing tomorrow is uh
open problems and happy hour um so
what's going to happen is we'll have
another one of these speed talk things
and then after that we'll all migrate up
to the second floor where there will be
food and Beverages and whiteboards and
uh I think we're going to try to
pre-populate the whiteboards with some
of the open questions that youall have
been writing on the zulip Forum so now
is the time to put an open question
there if uh if you have one in mind and
you haven't um because then we'll we'll
pick some and you can vote on them also
just like add emojis or something and we
we we'll take the most some of the most
popular ones and put them up on
whiteboards and then folks can kind of
yeah cluster around and I don't know
either solve all of them or at least
form some collaborations and start CH
chatting um but so this is just
announcement telling you uh if you
haven't already started thinking about
open problems that you might want to
post on the zulip now's a good time all
right so without further Ado let's get
on to the speed talks our uh first
speaker is Ray Lee from Santa Clara
University uh ready take it away thanks
so I'll be talking about deletion codes
and LCS and this is based on joint works
with vcat
and
oops so I'll be telling you two stories
about deletion codes and longest common
subsequences the first one is about
deletion codes so I'm going to start
with a combinator question and if you if
you've seen this before don't say
anything so we're going to start with a
warm-up question which I promise you is
easy what is the largest set of binary
strings we can find such that the LCS
between any two is at most n over two so
we want a large set of binary strings
such that you know any two are far apart
and that they have small long as common
subsequence okay so um any
guesses up is it two it is two yes uh so
the answer is two you can take the all
zero string and the all one string and
um these have LCS zero so it certainly
satisfies the uh requirements uh and if
you have three strings then there are
two strings with say at least as many
ones as zeros um are the same majority
bit so their LCS is n/ two so you notice
here the I didn't say this LCS is um uh
not necessarily consecutive um
sub this a simple question um so now
let's uh relax this a bit right this is
a very simple question Simple Solution
okay now let's say we want LCS par wise
LCS you know n / 2 plus Epsilon n for
some absolute Epsilon so this is a you
know like a relaxation so it's a relax
constraint so potentially we could find
more strings so now the question is how
many strings can we
find so this turns out to be quite a
difficult question so before our work uh
there was a double exponential gap
between the best upper and lower bounds
the best uh construction had you know
roughly log end strings and it's given
you know something it looks something
like what I've shown on the right and
the best upper bound was not much better
than the um you know the trivial you
know two to the N exponential type bound
okay so you can improve the constant in
the exponent but it's um double
exponential
Gap and the main contribution of our
work was to improve the upper bound from
exponential type to a quasi polinomial
type so to be precise about the
quantifiers we show that in any set of
binary strings that sufficiently large
quasi polinomial size there are two
strings with LCS n /2 plus um Epsilon n
for some absolute
constant so this is a combinatorics
result uh but it also has a deletion
code interpretation um so the statement
is that there are no ASM totically
positive rate error correcting codes
correcting this 0.5 minus some Delta
fraction of worst case
delions so this is again the
combinatorics result and how do you
translate this combinatorics thing into
the deletion codes thing well c as the
notation might suggest is an error
correcting code and this is saying for
any error correcting code that um is
this size so this includes all positive
rate codes uh for any positive rate code
we have this condition which um is
equivalent to saying that it doesn't
correct um that many worst case
Solutions okay this is a some result
about you know there are no positive
rate error correcting codes correcting
this fraction of worst case
Solutions so this is some fundamental
result about deletion code so maybe I'll
spend just one more slide explaining
what this is okay or why why this is
fundamental so uh insertion deletion
error correcting codes were originally
studied by lein man and um there's this
you know classic result that says a code
correcting deletion a code corrects PN
worst case deletions if any two strings
have par wise small LCS um par wise LCS
less than n minus P * n
Okay so we've got you know our
definition of a noise model and you know
in coding Theory we often measure some
uh how good a code is by the rate so you
can ask you know what is the optimal
trade-off between the rate and the noise
tolerance right we asked this in all
kinds of context and coding Theory let's
ask this for deletions which is this
very you know mathematically fundamental
model so this is an open question I've
kind of sketched you know very sketchily
you know what is the best trade-off
between r&p but this is open okay so
maybe this is this is open but maybe
that's not so embarrassing because we
know even for erasers and substitutions
this is still open right there's the GV
bound and these linear programming
bounds right so we don't know it even
for substitutions uh but it is our the
the State of Affairs is uh somewhat
embarrassing we don't even know what is
uh for what values of P can we have are
bigger than zero so um we don't know for
what values of P can we have ASM
totically positive rate codes so you can
imagine this this big open question is
asking about this this curve of optimal
this trade-off curve of R versus P
values and this open and embarrassing
question is just asking about what is
the P intercept of this curve so it's
just asking for you know one point on
this curve and you know by contrast you
know this has been known for
substitutions and erasers since at least
at least since 1960 maybe earlier um
this is the plot Kim bound that will
show that you know for substitution you
can't do better than a quarter and your
ratio is like a half um so this is like
e not too hard to prove for substitution
any ratios but for deletions it's still
open so for deletions there's this a
simple argument that you can't do
correct better than half fraction of
deletions right this is actually
equivalent to the combinatorics easy
quator question I showed you on the
first slide so you can't do better than
a half and um so there was this you know
extra embarrassing question of could you
have codes that uh are positive rate and
correct all the way up to a half so for
some half minus Epsilon could you have
positive rate codes and we didn't know
whether you could rule out this or find
a code right and the contribution of our
workor was to at least at least resolve
this embarrassment and to say you know
no you actually can't get all the way to
a half there's some for some absolute
you know Epsilon you can't correct half
minus Epsilon fraction still compatible
with your number
sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the
same oh
yes all right so that's the first story
I want to tell and um so I was giving a
talk on on this on on this um on this
result and S said again who works in
algorithms was in the audience and he
mentioned that there is this related
problem on um approximation algorithms
for LCS and it turns out that they're
superficially similar but actually you
know we we able to use techniques from
this to solve this other problem so even
though this is a coding Theory session
I'll tell you about application of these
techniques and
algorithms so um so you all know from
algorithms that uh you know you can
compute the LCS of two strings in O of n
s time using dynamic programming if
they're length n and um you could ask
out their faster algorithms and there's
all these results in find grain
complexity that says well you can do a
little bit better but if you want to do
you know truly sub quadratic time you
can't do this assuming you know um you
know plausible fine grain complexity
hypothesis okay so you can't do better
than um quadratic time substantially
better than quadratic time so you could
ask well can you get faster
approximation algorithms and if you are
doing LCS for two binary strings there's
a simple 1/ half approximation in uh
linear time you just count the number of
zeros and ones and um you can prove this
in one line that this does the right
thing okay so there's a simple half
approximation so you could naturally ask
can you get a half plus Epsilon
approximation um and so it was known uh
by Ruben Stan song you could do this if
the strings are the same length but uh
somehow this really crucially used that
the strings are the same length and um
using some ideas from the deletion codes
work we were able to show you can
actually do this even if the strings are
unequal length
okay and sort of the the the the the the
the main uh exciting part is that we use
the same techniques as we do in the
deletion codes bound so it kind of
builds this bridge between the coding
question and this algorithmic
question okay so now I'll say a little
bit more about what's the connection
here so you notice the first the the
algorithmic result is a you know this
we're getting a half plus Epsilon
approximation of binary longest common
subsequence this other thing is um some
combinatorics was all about longest
common subsequence
and the combinatorics result it's a
negative results about deletion codes
and this is a positive out Ric result so
how could they be similar but if you
think about the deletion codes result
it's actually more of a positive result
in the algorithmic sense because you are
showing like you look at the quantifiers
there exists like this long Common
subsequence in these two strings so it's
kind of a positive result in the
algorithmic sense so um you might
suspect there's something um in common
and they have this theme of they're both
breaking this trivial one half barrier
like there's this you know getting one
half is Trivial and then but getting
half plus Epsilon is somehow very
difficult um so for both of these we
break this trivial one half barrier uh
and we do it with similar ideas um and
since it's a 10-minute talk I don't have
to say anything about the or I don't
have to go into detail about the
techniques because it's very annoying or
very technical um but uh the highest
level ideas we come up with this uh
thing that's roughly analogous to a for
transform for Strings so it's a
structure Lemma that classifies strings
by the this oscillation frequency
and um if you want to know more about
this I can chat
offline uh and so there's a bunch of
open questions here both for like the
approximation algorithms and for the
deletion codes there's a lot more that
aren't on this slide and um happy to
chat about any so that's all
thanks we have time for one to question
while the next speaker sets
up is this connection between code an
algorithm like does it depend on the
specific EP that you have or is
something more
General is the connection between codes
and algorithms epon that you have from
the negative result uh it's it's a
slightly different Epsilon but I think
that's more of just like when we do
these different when we do the
connection we don't it's kind of lossy
but uh if you improve the codes then you
improve the the prion algorithm or not
yes but I think it'll still be bad
unless you really refine the algorithm
well let's thank Ray
again and uh next up we have chrishna
narian from Texas A&M got the mic all
working can you hear me great thank you
Mary all right so I am interested in
understanding how list recoverable codes
may be of use for some multiple access
problems that I've been thinking about
in wireless networks I'm going to spend
most of this time I'm trying to describe
the context on the problem and maybe POS
a few questions so the problem we've
been interested in is you have a
wireless network you have a large number
of users in a network but only a small
set of them are active at any given time
so let's say we have K users in a
network who are active each one of them
has a b bit message that they want to
send and typically what happens is that
they encode this message using an error
correcting code and let's say that for
the purposes of this talk that this is a
code over
fq and so I'm going to use C sub IJ to
refer to the I symbol in the code word
of the J
user and then usually what happens
is these symbols get mapped to real or
complex vectors and they're actually
transmitted through the channel now this
is where all the algebraic structure of
the code gets destroyed so I'm not going
to worry too much about what happen
happens underneath this and I'm going to
try to explain the coding problem that
may be relevant so a lot happens
here we don't need to care too much
about this but in the end we're going to
abstract this into saying what the
receiver gets to
see is the set of symbols that were
transmitted by the J users at each time
instant so there are two versions of
this problem in one version you get to
observe the set but you don't get to see
the multiplicity of the symbols if two
people were to pick the same symbol at
the same time and transmit you know that
the symbol was transmitted you don't
really know how many people transmitted
it and in the other version you get to
see the multiplicities as well so you
know exactly what symbols were
transmitted and how many such of them
were transmitted and your job of course
is to find which code words were
transmitted by the users so you can
already see this looks very much like a
list recoverable code Type uh set
setup in the communication Theory area
this was first the problem was described
in 1981 by by Chang and wolf and there
were some information theoretic results
and even some code constructions for
this but the thing that's different now
is that when you typically do
information theoretic proves in these
multi-user
situations you inherently somehow assume
that these codes are all different like
if you go to the standard proes of
achieving capacity on the multi-us
channels these codes are typically
different and in practice the way this
might work is that your base station
will have to tell each person to pick
some parameters in the code that are
somehow
different now recently there is a lot of
interest in trying to do away with this
Paradigm and the problem with the base
station telling people what code to pick
is is that there is overhead and there
is we want to get rid of this overhead
so we want to go to a paradigm where we
say we're going to force every user to
pick exactly the same code so I have K
users B bits they're all going to pick
exactly the same code they're going to
transmit and then you get to observe the
set of symbols that were transmitted at
each time and we want to recover the set
of transmitted code wordss so this is
what we call as the unsourced multiple
access problem because now we don't
really care about who transmited w we
only care about which set of code words
were
transmitted and it turns out that the
typical metric we are interested
in is the per user error probability so
what we want to say is this the decoder
is tasked with producing a list of code
words that were transmitted and you say
that I'm willing to accept the
probability with which an actual
transmitted code word is not in the list
to be some Epsilon
now I know that some of you may have a
interest in this Epsilon being zero but
I think all of these is of interest you
know sometimes you may want this Epsilon
to be really small sometimes you don't
care about this Epsilon being somewhat
big I think I think all these regimes
are of
interest um all right so what I
described so far is the error free model
right so in this case you get to observe
exactly what was transmitted perhaps
with multiple or without multiplicity
but it's also possible oops I think this
is a mistake this should be an uh that
that should be an eraser there so
sometimes it's possible that the symbols
are erased completely you have
interference and then you lose those
symbols it's also possible
that you get a list of symbols which are
more than the list of transmitted
symbols so for example you may have
errors it's also possible that some
things are flipped many kinds of error
models are are possible in particular
it's also possible that you get soft
decisions which means you might get the
probability with which a particular
symbol was transmitted at time I or
not all these things are possible and
all right so recently there has been
interest trying to find some kinds of
bound so one information theoretic
result that's relevant is to say that to
compute an upper bound on the error
probability given the number of users
the size of the field the length of the
code and the rate of the
code I think this was more or less they
looked at random codes over fq and then
I think they computed some information
theoretic bounds and this is available
and so here are some questions I
interested in first of all I want to
know is this exactly the same setup in a
typical list recoverable code more or
less at least is the noiseless version
right out of the bad solve do we know
everything we need to know about this
that's first
question second question for a given
Epsilon can we characterize or or for a
given set of parameters for a given
length number of users size of the field
and
Epsilon can we characterize the rate of
somehow see
whether we can do better than this bound
so the they more or less analyzed a
random code and they came up with some
upper bounds there is no reason to
believe there is any optimality to this
to this uh to the to the random code so
can we beat
this um so this is like an achievability
that's an achievability
bound yeah that's an achievability bound
we may be able to beat this um thirdly
as an engineer
I'm interested in things that have low
complexity I'm interested in things that
have complexity that scale somewhat
nicely with K the number of
users and finally I'm interested in
seeing if there are versions
of the cter Varity type algorithms where
you may be able to take soft information
into account when in somehow doing the
list
decoding think these are some of the
questions I thought were interesting
there is recently one result that I have
seen where they people have tried to use
list recoverable codes more or less in
the same setup um and they provide some
empirical comparisons to other things
that people have done and indeed it
seems like they are helpful um and uh we
can talk more about that later so how
much time do I
have couple minutes okay so I I I want
to say one more thing I mean this may be
very obvious to some people who are
working in this field
before but I feel like this version of
the multiple access problem is more or
less isomorphic to a compress sensing
problem one to one and and there is
something I I I feel like we can learn
from both of these so clearly if you
think about this problem of saying you
know I have K users each wanting to
transmit B bits of information so one
way to think about this problem is to
say let me think of a a vector of
Dimension 2 raised to B and each one of
these B bits gets mapped to an index
between 1 and 2 to the B and so what I
end up transmitting is actually this
index Vector multiplied by a sensing
Matrix and what I get to observe is that
plus noise so anytime I can solve this
problem I essentially solve this problem
and if I want to solve this problem I
could try to solve this problem first
and and try to uh get a solution for
this but the problem is that typically
we are interested in B being you know
even if B is 100 we're talking about
incredibly large dimensions in the
compress sensing problem so it's kind of
naive to think that you can solve the
compress sensing problem as it is by
throwing standard solvers at the
compress sensing problem so what you
really want to do is to use some
structured sensing Matrix which lets you
reduce the complexity and I would like
it to be polinomial in K the number of
um active users or the number of
non-zero indices in this um and and one
of the things that we have tried is this
is something that may resonate well with
many of you is is um to do a kind of a
divide and conquer strategy so one thing
to do is to say let me take my B bits of
information let me add some redundancy
to this so I'm going to encode it
strictly over the binary field and then
what I will do is I will split this
Vector into smaller
chunks and then I use a compress sensing
algorithm to be able to convey the index
that corresponds to each one of these
smaller chunks so now we have K users
each one of them sending these smaller
chunks so essentially what you then get
is back to this list recoverability
problem so I have these n slots and I
know the set of symbols that were
transmitted in each one of them and I
need to stitch them together somehow I
have to do the list recoverability and
what we used in this case are these
parity bits to stitch these pieces
together so we call this as a tree code
so what you do is you you put some
parity bits in here which are all linear
combinations of the bits that are that
that appear before that particular block
now what that lets you do is it lets you
build a tree and then prune the tree the
ones that don't satisfy the parity check
you can prune them and you can throw
them out this has a case qu complexity
it turns out to perform reasonably well
but by no means the best you can do and
I perhaps there are constructions of
list recoverable codes that can do
better than this and I'm I'm I'm
interested in Le more about
[Applause]
this quick question while the next
speaker said something just a comment
that for compress sensing we know how to
do decoding in linear time the number of
rows of the Matrix which can be
exponentially exped the number of cols
that you're concerned
about what kind of constructions are
these there are a few that are almost
optimal as well actually so there are
sever near time ones for for matrices
and you can also construct matrices like
based on expander graphs and other
stuff can use Simple tricks like beit
maxing bat masking and there are also
more complicated ones but even if you
want close to linear it's it's not hard
okay yeah I mean I would be curious to
see that because they might be able to
Port that onto the the multiple access
problem more or less sorry doesn't want
complexity Le in the number of signals
instead of the Matrix size linear in the
number of Roads the number of Cl to
theity yeah I think the number of rows
will be roughly K log n right K is the
number of users and N is the dimension
of the so it might be roughly K log in
and that would that would be good
enough maybe we could take the the
further discussion offline I think you
successfully the
audience
all right and next up we have uh Ken
Brown from duke who will tell us about
something on the
board so while it's setting up I should
also say how how are the constants in
these linear time are they
pretty good I
think okay uh I'm Ken
Brown
uh I'm from duke I do not I have a few
theorems I don't usually try to solve
theorems uh the main reason I'm here is
I'd like people in this audience to
solve theorem swarming so let me talk
about problems so
um you know if we have this simple idea
of an
encoder and a
channel and a
decoder
um this is the the basically the idea we
use when we think about making these
Quantum Eric correcting codes so the
only thing that
changes is the encoder is now two codes
somehow put together
and then at the end we can measure the
code and
decode but uh as someone who builds
Quantum correcting codes in the
laboratory the laboratory is very far
from this because the encoder doesn't
work the decoder doesn't work and then
normally this channel is too long so you
do some kind of quantum error correction
in the middle and when you do this
Quantum error correction in the middle
um you know this key
idea is that you measure these syndromes
and you don't actually get access
directly to the data so you don't
actually learn anything about the state
and uh from the last uh session right I
only learn you know I want to be in this
black Cube but I'm in one of these red
cubes so the only information I learn is
which of these red cubes I'm in then I
fix
it so when you think about about
um uh yeah so let's just let's just
think about how this works so if I have
the surface
code it has you know starts off with bad
parameters no rate uh but it's worse
because the way we make the
encoder is actually the same as this
Quantum error correcting channel so we
measure the syndrome
sare of
N and so when we think about
the we think about the uh Quantum
circuit this Quantum circuit we
implement
so we often talk um in Quantum fall and
Quantum Eric rection of this SpaceTime
volume so for these topological codes
this SpaceTime volume is d^2 time D and
then I want to say that lately in the
field there's been a lot of good work on
um uh yeah like really recently
SpaceTime
codes clet codes which kind of slightly
break the coding
picture
um different types of cluster
States um all right so the all right so
that's okay I'll take a question here
hopefully this makes sense from an's
talk the other talks on air correction
good everyone's happy why do you have on
see this uh because I can't trust any of
these syndrome
measurements so each
layer each layer gives me a
syndrome but this syndrome is wrong and
so I
repeat some number of times and for this
code typically repeat D times
and then you're able to run a decoder
that runs over this whole SpaceTime
block to figure out what WR yeah
anything the vertical axis is time and
then then the measuring D times is so
that you're now have D you know dult
tolerance right
because probability as
FP yes that's right so so this model
assumes errors happen with the same
probability any errors but yeah that
basically um in this kind of model the
geometric distance is the distance so
the space distance is D to get from one
boundary to the other and then the time
distance is D because you need that many
times to distinguish between something
like if you had a measurement that
failed D over2 times in the same spot
your syndrome is way off so you have to
kind of get to D over2 plus one
to so it's well known that um service
codes correct a constant fraction of
Errors they have a positive
threshold D is only D there it possible
they still have a constant threshold
with syndrome errors even if you did it
to like three levels maybe that hasn't
have to be D for a constant fraction
threshold okay so that's a great point
so so there are other
codes um which have this
property sometimes called single
shot um which promises that you don't
have to go to D errors for your code
it's possible to do less
errors um but it's also true that for
local for spatially local checks of the
surface code that that doesn't exist for
surface
code more
questions all right so now um for
something
different uh yeah no one right no one
has talked about measurement based
Quantum computing
so there's a direct
map from
this to something which is D to the
three2
cubits and this thing is called a
cluster
State and in this cluster State each
layer looks a lot like
this but now time is really space and
the process of um
moving information transforming
information it's just measuring up
through this cluster
State and there's been a lot of work on
this which is called foliated there are
also some cool not cluster States called
non-foliated where there's not exactly a
code which connects back to this flow
codes where there's not exactly a code
and that leads to the thing I want to
talk about which is I can write down
these circuits right so I basically just
have a bunch of
cubits
um I have a bunch of unitary
Gates and then I have some measurements
here and
there and these
objects this this kind of General
SpaceTime code could describe either of
these objects as
fine um but when I think about these
errors as we learned in the last talk
the key error that we always use is we
take some number of
cubits and we replace it with the
identity on that
block and that identity
block we we we normally assume that it
acts on the support of the gates in the
circuit now we can always decompose this
um depolarizing Channel
as the
application of some M Cubit poly
operator
um onto the
circuit and so what's what I'm
interested so okay
so so right now most of the time when we
do this work to make fault tolerant
Quantum
computation we assume there's a
Code we get this code by assuming
there's a channel
but our
Channel actually comes
from most of the errors in the channel
comes from creating the code and looking
for
syndromes so so the our choice of this
is what makes the
channel and so
uh I guess I was inspired um by the
tutorials on Tuesday which to me this is
kind of like a weird insertion deletion
problem so you have a function like a
you have a
function which is evaluating this
Quantum
circuit and the yeah circuit
circuit the circuit is just a list of
gates and the
noise is
basically inserting unwanted Gates so
this is just an insertion right so I'm
just inserting unwanted
Gates but I want the output to be the
same as long as the number of inserted
Gates is less than my whatever distance
my distance on my
circuit so what yes what I'm very
interested in is trying to think if we
can build our fault tolerance circuits
this way without having to think about
code channels CH channels built for
codes so we know like it turns out
channels built for codes will solve this
problem but it'd be nice if we had um in
the same way we can think about you know
class codes that are made for insertion
deletion can we think about Vault
tolerant Quantum circuits that are made
for insertion
delation that's that's my thing I want
people
looking more questions any questions
yeah so then does more tangibly does
this abstraction mean that the code
needs to be designed around the circuit
instead is kind of what you're getting
at because the the the the reason why it
feels in congruent to me between
insertion deletion is
um you can
shift Gates right and that's actually
okay in a circuit yes right so it's
it's it's it's not immediate that it
goes back to the binary Co binary um
like that over the field case right
because in that case you're literally
like shifting indices and those objects
are are different right yeah so so so so
that's a great way to think about it so
um so if I think about the surface code
I can correct um you know up to whatever
D
over2
weight D2 poly
right this whole mechanism here the
reason why I have to measure D
times is to
guarantee that this output surface isn't
clean but that the output surface has
errors that are less than
this um so
that's so so so it's this sort of weird
thing where uh I can push all the errors
following my fault tolerant procedures
out to the end which then defines my
channel and there's kind of um
I don't know how to say it's like this
interactive Loop right so I picked this
surface code because oh I have poly
errors on a channel on my memory Channel
but then I can't encode it and I can't
decode it I have to do this like layer
of thing and then I'm like oh man this
is only going to work if the errors come
out at the end at D over2 and so I use
that to construct this circuit and then
why did I bother with the surface code
at the bottom what really matters is the
circuit and this is starting to show up
in these SpaceTime codes and fet codes
and these nonfoliated cluster
States but these these codes have still
mostly kind of followed from the
examples that we have of these
topological
codes does that wait okay let me
rephrase that what I've heard
[Applause]
so next up we have a
Hano um you have slides
[Music]
yes I'll just hold
it do you want to can use this thing if
you
want
okay so I'll quick uh uh I'll take this
chance thank you Mary for holding the
speed talk I'll take this chance to give
a quick introduction to our recent work
with uh Wally Christian Alex and Henry
oh uh I'm H H ya from duke about uh this
work is about uh how uh uh we managed to
improve the BPD coding performance of qu
a PC
codes okay so I'll fly over the setup
for um the syndrome decoding problem on
Quant uh RBC code really quick because
like uh there are many Quantum session
introducing the like the CSS code and
the stabilizer setup already so um here
we'll be looking at uh the decoding
problem of CSS codes and the error model
uh I'll look at the like the the B basic
like a really simplest error model well
where we only have like a bit flip error
independent bit flip error with
probability PX and uh because CSS code
the the stabilizer that correct the B
flip error are separate from stabilizer
that correct the face flip error so
basically correcting X error is the same
as correcting Z error so I'll focus on
the just the X error here for this talk
and the the synr rec calling problem is
that um given a syndrome which is the
which is the product the the aror vector
with the the stabilizer Matrix
HZ uh the decoder would like to find um
an error uh with this syndrome that
maximize the conditional
probability okay but the problem with
Quan alpc code uh but the problem with
qu CSS code is that um it has code
degeneracy so uh CSS code for into the
category of stabilizer code where the
code space is defined by the uh by the
space that uh that's unchange under the
stabilizer operators so if we find any
error uh any correct error plus a
stabilizer as our decoding
result uh this decoding is still
successful because when we try to
recover the space uh we will first
apply uh ex try to move it back to the
original code space and then apply a
stabilizer because the stabilizer
doesn't change the the cubeit doesn't
change the original code space so if we
invert this
operation uh to apply like a an error
correction plus a stabilizer uh this is
still a a correct decoding answer for
this problem so this is called code decy
and uh you will think that this is
pretty good because this this means when
we try to do the syndrome uh when we try
to uh solve the syndrome decoding
problem there are many many correct
answers like all the answer differ by
stabilizers are essentially equivalent
but however this to pose a problem when
we try to apply the BPD coding because
unlike classical case uh there's only
one correct answer but in the Quan audpc
case there are many correct answers uh
up to differ of the
stabilizers so BL propagation decoding
is a m message passing algorithm on a
datagraph and uh it was originally
designed uh in uh to uh it has excellent
performance for the classical adpc codes
uh however uh when polyon uh so polyon
uh in 2028 uh are the first uh work that
try to apply to the quantum syr decoding
problem however when people try to apply
BP to Quantum it doesn't work as well
because of code degeneracy so basically
there are many different correct answer
that both can attract can attract the
BBD coding process that makes it very
hard to
converge okay so after and transfers uh
effort to apply bp2 Quantum there are
many works that try to improve the BP
decoding performance and um uh spoiler
alert at the end I'll show a curve
compare with BPD and bpsi with our
algorithm so uh we propose to use BP gu
decimation to decode qu LPC codes so BPG
was earlier
introduced um to solve the constraint
satisfaction problem and later apply
apply to the lossy compression problem
where the setup is there are many uh
where where the setup is there are many
correct answer and it suffice to just
find one of them and uh uh uh the BP GD
algorithm that we're going to use here
uh work as follows so we're going to run
many rounds of BP and after each round
after running BP in each round for T
iterations we will if the if if the BP
algorithm hasn't converged meaning we
haven't find error that match the
syndrome we will pick the most reliable
bit notes based on the BP soft
information and fix this value fix it
value to either zero or one based on
this bias and then we go into the next
run and we run BP for another iterations
we fix another bit and we keep going
like this until either uh BP finds a
convergent error which match the
syndrome or we have fixed all the bits
in the tgraph and we still haven't found
the correct
answer so this is uh how bbgd works and
the idea is that the bbgd basically uh
uh and the intuition we have behind this
algorithm applying to Quantum is a
approximate a sampling process because
by running BP for sufficient number of
iterations the thought information we
get for each for a single bit note for
example approximate the lock likelihood
ratio of the the sum of the
probabilities of the wordss uh where we
have a the correct answers where we have
a zero at this location versus the sum
of the probabilities of the correct
answers where we have one in this
location so um by fixing this uh bit Noe
to either zero or one we basically throw
away half of the space and we narrow uh
narrow down uh narrow down our search
space okay so the
curve is here here here we present our
simulation curves compare with both BP
showing in the blue curve BPD in red and
another work in 2022 by chesma and
S um which proposed to improve BP with
stabilizing activation I'm going to skip
their method but uh here you can show
all the comparison here we we run it for
two different codes the B1 code and the
C2 code uh constructed in the pantal and
K's paper in
2019 the B1 is um generalized hyper
product construction and C2 follows a
hyper product
construction and uh the performance is
pretty
good that's the punch line of this
[Laughter]
talk that would be
it
questions does the variant of VP that
you use here make a difference sorry
does the variant of VP that you use here
make a difference we just use some
product uh the basic some product
algorithm uh like I I haven't tried like
other there are many variants of BP
including mean some or like normalized
BP for example but I haven't tried those
I just run the most basic s prod
algorithm and the performance already
pretty impressive so I'm happy about
it
let's thank speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
again short break for for technology and
erasing
on I turned it
off next we have sorry next up we have
uh Jason Pollock um who will tell us
about something on the
board yeah good hi I'm Jason I'm from
Syracuse um good so I want to build on
what the picture chimme gave earlier
today about error
correction um where the idea is we've
got some space and Quantum states of a
physical system this is a bad marker to
choose we've got some space of quantum
states of a physical
system to know H Hilbert space and um
the physical system encodes a logical
Subspace um which is a Subspace of the
physical c space and then I have some um
error Channel
which takes me to a different point in
the hbert space and this is a good code
if the canola F conditions are met so um
this doesn't actually affect where I am
in The Logical space there exists a
recovery Channel such that the
composition of the eror channel and
Recovery Channel takes me back to the
same state okay so I want to consider
the generalization which goes by the
name of operator algebra Quantum error
correction where the idea is essentially
that I have a restriction on the type of
recovery that I'm allowed to do I'm only
allowed to apply some restricted set of
operations in the physical Hilbert space
and so intuitively what you might think
is that okay uh this means that I can't
reconstruct the full state in The
Logical Hilbert space but I can res
reconstruct some portion of it but if
you remember what chin may pointed out
is that um logical States logical code
words are locally indistinguishable so
the sense in which I can reconstruct a
portion of the information is not just
oh I take some portion of the cubits in
The Logical Hilbert space it's something
more soft so I need to tell you how to
define that and in order to do that we
need to think about not just the space
of States but the space of operators
linear operators acting on the space of
States um and so this goes by the name
of vanoyan algebra so um what I'm going
to use RoR and algeb to do is I'm going
to um Define something called the
algebraic state which uh tells me about
um what information I can recover from a
state if I have access to a specific set
of observations I can make and then I
will use that to Define um the key
Notions in operator algebra error
correction which are the notion of
privacy and correctability of of an
noyman algebra with respect to a channel
and then hopefully I'll have time to
tell you about um some results um which
we know in particular special cases of
channels okay so um let me Define a van
noyman
algebra is this marker okay should I use
a different marker maybe get a different
one away don't put it
back all right
um uh of annoyment algebra m is a subset
of the space of operators on some
Hilbert
space um such that
um all operators in
the annoyment algebra have the following
properties so
um if o is an M then if there's two o's
in M then there
some is an m so it's an additive group
their product is an m so it's a
multiplicative
group the ad
joint OD dagger is an M um and then
finally and this is the
key thank you this is like my class too
um always have this problem okay the key
defining extra feature here which
separates this from just a standard
algebra is that um every scal or
multiple of the
identity
um C * I the identity element in the
group is
an okay um
so in general for our infinite
dimensional Hilbert spaces this is a
quite complicated object but for a
finite dimensional hbert space the space
of linear operators is just the space of
matrices so this is just some algebra of
matrices that contains the
identity um a simple way to generate
this is if I pick some
set of self adjoint matrices permission
matrices and I formed the multiplicative
group generated by those things and then
I take the span of that multiplicative
group this automatically gives me a vom
in algebra so I first use the
multiplicative properties and then I use
the additive properties
um okay so if I have a vinom algebra M I
can also Define the commutant of M which
is denoted by this Prime which is the
space of
operators um
that
commute
with every element in the vanoyan
algebra and then I can form the center
which is the intersection of M and M
Prime so that's the space of operators
in M which commute with all other
elements in m so the identity all of the
identity um multiples of the identity
always lives in the center but very
importantly sometimes you can also have
additional elements in the center which
don't look like the identity and when
that's the case there's some non-trivial
symmetry which is preserved by all the
operations in the vman algebra that's
what having some nonidentity element of
the center
means
um good
so there's sort of two key facts about
voman
algebras which make them useful so the
first is the B commutant theorem which I
believe V noyman realized which is just
this statement the commutant of the
commutant gives you the algebra itself
this is where this assumption four was
important because um otherwise uh I
might get all of the identity multiples
even if they weren't originally an m and
this would not be
true essentially because of this
statement you can prove a classification
theorem about vman algebras which says
that um I can always decompose a voman
algebra into
pieces such that each individual piece
only has identity elements in the centor
so the Symmetry lives in the individual
blocks and each individual block itself
just looks like um something with no
extra
symmetries um so this is known as the
veter bur decomposition
theorem um the statement
is for any vanoyan algebra um acting on
a finite dimensional Hilbert space then
I can decompose the Hilbert space into
pieces these each
alphas and H
betas um such that I can write any
element of M as a block diagonal matrix
in this
decomposition okay and in particular
this immediately tells you that for any
state in the Hilbert
space um there exists what's known as
the algebraic state in M such that the
expectation value of
o measured in state s is equal to the
expectation value of o in the algebraic
state for all o in the subalgebra so
this is precisely the object we wanted
this is the thing which tells us about
all of the information that you get for
measuring um elements of M and nothing
else okay um and in
particular I have a state I can also
Define an entropy an algebraic entropy
um which essentially in each of these
blocks I have a matrix and so there's a
piece which comes from the Shannon
entropy across the different blocks and
then there's a piece which comes with
Van the vanoyan entropy within the
individual
blocks okay so using vanoyan algebras um
in the 2010s there was this theory of
operator algebra error correction
developed and the key concepts are
privacy and correctability
um so writing these down precisely
requires a little more Channel
technology than we've probably seen so
I'll just say this verbally um so let's
think
of the
setup
um where that I drew here um I've got an
error channel it's acting on the
physical space of States um and that
then has some implication for how things
move around in The Logical Subspace so
the idea is if I have
some subalgebra of the operators in The
Logical Subspace I think it's
correctable with respect to the channel
if I can recover from the error so again
I can't recover the state fully but I
can recover The Logical State row
M on the other hand um a subalgebra is
it with respect to the error if when I
look at the effect on the state it just
acts as a member of the commutant of m
and so it commutes with a logical state
so something is correctable if I can use
it to change to um any other operator in
The Logical Hilbert space something is
private if I can't use it to affect the
algebraic State at
all um and it was realized sort of
immediately in these papers that um
there is a relation between privacy and
correctability
essentially um if M is correctable for a
channel then there is a dual channel for
which it is privit so there's an
important special case here which I
think uh is easier to get some intuition
for so this is the case that was just
talked about a few speed talks ago which
is the Eraser channel uh so in the case
of the Eraser Channel well the idea is
that my Hilbert space
divides into two pieces A and B
and I want to be able to reconstruct The
Logical state only from the a degrees of
freedom or from the B degrees of
freedom so say I have correctability
with respect to um erasing B that means
that um there is some operator which
acts only on ha such that it's effect on
The Logical Hilbert space is to get me
any operator in HL so let me let me me
write that down for all o in M there
exists some
OA which is in ha which acts on ha such
that um o l is equal
to the projection of O A times the
identity in
b
onto
um The Logical Hilbert space so I'm
being a little vague what I mean by the
projection onto the logical Hilbert
space but essentially the definition of
a code tells you how to find the
Subspace L HL inside H by specifying
some isometry which is like some
function of the coordinates in the
larger Hilbert space I can get to get
the smaller one and so if I know that
isometry I can project operators onto
it okay and then similarly privacy means
that for all OA in L
ofha um this projection commutes with
every operator in um
HL okay so now the physics shows up um
and it shows up because of the biomutant
theorem um there is a very strong
constraint which is is placed on codes
um that allow me to recover information
both from a and from B so this is known
as complimentary
recovery and the idea is basically this
physical picture here where I imagine
that my um physical Hilbert space is a
circle here divided into two pieces A
and B and then The Logical Hilbert space
lives in the interor interior of this
circle and it breaks up into two pieces
which are M and M
Prime so
um this a code that has this properties
is a code which knows about the division
of the physical Hilbert space into these
two pieces in the sense that this piece
contains all of the information in m and
this piece contains all of the
information in the commutant of M and
both contain the information the center
because the center is the intersection
of those two things
um okay so because of the biomutant
theorem you can convert statements about
um privacy and correctability on M into
statements about correctability and
privacy on M Prime and so you get a very
stringent result uh which we proved a
few years ago uh which is essentially
there's two possibilities so possibility
one is if I take the set of all all
operators in a times the
identity and I project
that
onto uh
HL um this could be a vman algebra if it
is a vman algebra then it is the unique
vman algebra for which the code exhibits
complimentary
covering however it could also fail to
be a vanoyan algebra
because in particular like it could fail
to be closed under multiplication or to
contain the identity element or
something like this and when that
happens there is no vono and algebra for
which complimentary uh recovery
occurs umbe just one or two more minutes
yes good I want to say like one more
thing um okay so one more thing follows
from the classification theorem which
remember I told you in addition to an
algebraic State I could Define an
algebraic entropy it was shown by harlo
and collaborator
um a few years ago that um if I have a
code exhibiting complimentary recovery
for a bip
partition
um that is equivalent to saying for
every state in The Logical Hilbert space
there's some
operator which is in the center of the
code uh sorry in the center of the
vanoyan algebra such that
the difference between the entanglement
entropy of the physical
state across this
bipartition is equal to the algebraic
entropy of the
code of the algebraic entropy of the
state in the code
plus the expectation
value of this
operator um so this is relating a
entanglement entropy to the S the
entanglement entropy of a physical state
to the entropy of a code State plus the
expectation value of an operator and the
motivation for this was results in ads
CFT holography where there's a similar
statement where the the entropy in the
bulk sorry the entropy in the boundary
is equal to the bulk entropy plus the
expectation value of an area operator so
in this sense the idea is that this L
this is an operator it's an operator
that's in the center it's an operator
that's in the center which doesn't look
like the identity so this is telling you
something about um this code has some
symmetries and in particular it has the
symmetries which you would expect for a
code that has geometrical
structure you can divide it into pieces
like this
so um let me just close by saying I
think a very interesting question to ask
is what if I uh relax away
from um eras your errors so all of these
Notions of privacy and correctability go
through perfectly well for general
channels um it would be very interesting
if there is a result like this result of
harlo which tells you something more
General in these cases and if it's true
I would love to know it and what it
actually says
[Applause]
stop maybe one quick
question I I'll mention there's a
duality for codes and on classical cils
by Joseph renes which if if what you say
is true would probably be a very special
case of that but in that case it's
worked out in a generality yeah no I
think right the hard part here is um
going to the Eraser Channel saved me
from having to Define this notion of um
a dual Channel because in this case it
was sort of obvious that the Duel of
erasing one half of the Hilbert space is
erasing the other half of the Hilbert
space uh the hard part is to define a
duel in general I have to sort of lift
to a larger space of States
um in in the standard way that you can
re relate channels acting on a Hilbert
space to unitaries acting on like a a
product Hilbert space or something like
that and so like again the privacy and
correctability result exists it's not
immediately obvious to me that you could
do all of these these um like this is
sort of the hard detailed theorem the
rest sort of follows immediately from
proofs of findo an algeb I don't know if
you're familiar with that but I think
there's a special case that this worked
out in some detail great we should chat
about
that all right well let's uh thank the
speaker
again and let's thank all of the
speakers uh in this speed talk session
thanks
everybody and uh so that concludes the
programming for today